Let's see what implementing
instructive motion might look like.
In this example, we have a full bleed
image and some content below it.
There's a tension here,
we want to show the image in full, but
we also want to indicate that
there's more text available.
And perhaps, we want to show some of
that text content right away too.
What we can do is start off with
the image fully visible, but
then immediately slide up some of the
text to indicate there's more content.
Let's see how we can implement
this pretty simple form
of instructive motion.
Let's start with the layout.
Nothing fancy here, just a frame
layout with a fixed height image, and
a scroll view in front of it.
The linear layout in the scroll view
will contain our text content, and
have a white background.
We'll give the linear layout
a little elevation to make it clear
that it's a distinct surface.
Now, at the default scroll position,
you see the full image,
but very little text content.
All we need to do is
animate the scroll position
as the screen first opens to a position
that shows more of the text content.
Here we're using an ObjectAnimator
to animate the scrollY property
of the ScrollView.
We could just use the ScrollView's
smoothScrollTo method, but
this gives you a bit more
control over that animation.
We start the animation inside of
onEnterAnimationComplete to ensure that
the window transition ends first
before we start the animation.
This is only available in
Android 5.0 and later, but
you could fake it on earlier versions
using something like a start delay.
The effect is that you get a quick
preview of the image before you start
reading about it.
And you quickly realize you could
quickly scroll up to see that
image in full again or
down to read more.